I just wish I could experience it like
one episode give me one episode right
now like just drop me back in for a
couple the episode be about the family
some sort of internal struggle with the
family so a family heavy one I always
loved moments when Meadow and Tony got
quiet together and it was all our scenes
when we would get quiet together the
dialogue would actually be really
limited it would just be these like
heavy like pregnant pauses and Jim was
the typ type of scene partner where it
felt like he was there and his only
intention was to make me as good as I
could be wow and it had nothing to do
with him every time I wor with him I
felt like his sole purpose was I'm going
to make you I'm going to help you give
your best take Jamie when you're
so confident in yourself as a as a
performer that you just want to make the
other person it had nothing to do with
his confidence cuz he was actually not
he wasn't he was insecure oh my God yes